while vacation rentals are the trend in
other cities it is a different story
here in southern nevada short-term
rentals currently not permitted in
unincorporated clark county but the
nevada legislature has passed a new bill
that does require the county to regulate
short-term rentals at least do so by
july 1st sally jaramillo joining us now
live to explain how you can offer your
input into this process sally
brian and denise i spoke to many who
have mixed feelings about the short-term
rentals while some are forward others
are against it and they hope this survey
from the county simply brings in some
clarity
so short-term rentals such as airbnb are
illegal in unincorporated clark county
but they are allowed in some of the city
city of las vegas for example clark
county spokesman eric papa says with the
passage of legislation short-term
rentals will be allowed by july 1st
tuesday a public survey was launched to
get input from the public on an
ordinance that will be drafted to strike
a balance between the right of airbnb
operators to rent out their places on a
short-term basis burst is protecting the
integrity of our neighborhoods so we
have to strike an appropriate balance
and we really need the public's input
with assembly bill 363 it will require a
minimum distance of 500 feet between any
two short-term rentals as opposed to a
current las vegas ordinance which
requires 660 feet of space between each
residential property the proposal could
also override a city mandate that
requires a homeowner to occupy the
rental property are those standards
appropriate or should we require further
resistance requirements should we limit
the number of people that can stay in an
airbnb david kohlmeyer a retired
henderson police officer is concerned
about parties trash parking noise and
possibly crime i'm very much actually
against short-term rentals because a lot
of times background checks are not
followed cindy kester is a board member
of a valley hoa her only concern with
the survey is a variety of responses so
there's so many different
unanswered questions and i just don't
see the survey giving
our government officials the
answers
out here live the survey has multiple
questions for example how many people
can be in a home to how many nights in
the home and it only takes about 10 to
about 15 minutes to complete for now
reporting live sally haramiyo live local
now